Andthen,
if
you already the
country that I left is a country that the people
miss, it is the country of employment, it is the father
that the people had the right to live with
dignity with their heads held high in this country
and this country voting for corruption, listen to the
near  Throw in what to return the power
to you to continue doing the same
thing at Petrobras as the PT says, the
worse off the poorest people are, the better, it
's not for them to play politics over
me
[Music]
it's
the first meeting and
[Music]
What'sup
[Music] What's up
a
little [Music] What's
up
and your government was marked by
cryptography, in other words a government built on
theft your government was the
most corrupt government in the history of
Brazil the president who was in the know  that
my government is marked by the greatest
policy of social inclusion, the greatest
generation of employment, the greatest increase in the
minimum wage, the greatest investment
in family farming, the greatest
investment in the creation of the general law for
small businesses
[Music]
of you,
thinking of me, you have
you can't
make false accusations, my respect,
you are a disgrace to Brazilian journalism
What'sup?